if you want to do great things and you
need to be surrounded by greatness so
that you're at the office in the car
driving home use this video instead of
listening to the radio instead of
turning on music instead of putting on
an audiobook to help you come up with
greatness because it'll be the
soundtrack and the background for your
life
every day the first person there before
the Sun would be Jordan and he was there
because he wasn't good he would work
with a batting instructor and work all
day long and be the last person to leave
every night also as to what it was like
for him in the morning and Jordan said I
get up before the Sun comes up and I
make myself some breakfast by myself he
was down there alone and I get in the
car and I'm driving to spring training
and there's no one really out on the
roads yet and I look at the seat next to
me and I see my dad and I talked to him
I think to myself pops were doing this
we're doing this together and the day
would end and he would say to the
batting instructor when do a little more
I think I'm getting this I think I'm
learning this I think I'm getting this
and that's when Sports Illustrated put
him on the cover saying that Michael
Jordan is embarrassed baseball
and as I would watch him there every
night as the Sun was going down on the
other ball players have left and I would
see this guy working to get better
Michael Jordan working to get better I
couldn't help thinking that if you ever
have children
you ought to pray to take her up someday
when he or she like this.what in this
whole world turns you on challenge I
really just I just love I didn't love it
you know I love being told no it just
means yes no to you yeah what turned you
off lack of enthusiasm when it turns me
off hey I want to talk to you today
about success success duty obligation
responsibility if you approach it any
other way which most people are most
people think well I'll be successful if
the economy works I'll be successful if
something happens I'll be successful if
I win the lottery ticket look you're not
going to be successful if you don't
demand it if you literally don't stake a
claim to and say this is mine it's
important you're not gonna have it I
promise you I know I'm telling you from
experience I spent the first 25 years of
my life like like a spectator watching
other people get successful and then
wondering why was it success is your
duty it is your obligation and your
responsibility for longevity if you want
longevity is you gotta be picky with the
roles you choose and it's all about it
has to be on the page you know if if
it's if it's not written properly then
you have nothing so if you if you get a
script sent your way that they're
interested in you and and it's really
solid on the page then you have
something to work with but other than
that then no you see actually I do not
teach you know karate because I do not
believe in styles anymore I mean I do
not believe that there is such thing as
like Chinese way of fighting or the
Japanese Way of fighting or whatever way
you're fighting because I'm less human
being have three arms and four legs we
will have a different form of fighting
but basically we have only two hands in
two feet so style
tends to a not only separate man you
know because they have their own
doctrines and then the doctrine became
the gospel cheese you know that you
cannot change you know and but if you do
not have Styles if you just say well
here Here I am you know as as a human
being how can i express myself totally
and completely now that way you won't
create a style because style is a
crystallization you know I mean that way
it's a process of continuing growth
pretty professional basketball for the
Chicago Bulls 32 seconds to go one-point
lead for Georgetown
by the church my evolution and I'm the
Michael Jordan revolution it always had
to start back in college hitting a shot
against Georgetown in 1982 and I really
didn't know exactly what I was doing
it awakened a person inside of me to
excel to compete to excel to be one of
the best will be Phoebus that joking and
I guess with that shot it kind of
knighted a fire inside of a bed
that's what's gonna stop
the point is I'm pursuing something that
nobody looks too happy about it but
we're just looking out for your
interests I appreciate that but maybe
you're looking out for your interests
just a little bit more I mean you
shouldn't be asking people to come down
here and pay the freight on something
they paid it still ain't good enough I
mean you think that's right I mean maybe
you're doing your job of why I got to
stop me from doing mine because if
you're willing to go through all the
battling you got to go through to get to
where you want to get who's got the
right to stop you I mean maybe some of
you guys got something you never
finished something you really want to do
something you never said to someone
something and you're told no even after
you pay your dues who's got the right to
tell you that who nobody it's your right
to listen to your gut and ain't nobody's
right to say no after you earned the
right to be where you want to be and do
what you want to do you know the older I
get the more things I gotta leave behind
that's life the only thing I'm asking
you guys to leave on the table is what's
right almost 90% of sales managers say
they don't have time you know and again
it goes back to look if you knew it was
gonna bank you money today would you
make time for it so they would they
would make time for it cuz they make
time for the things that make of money
if you if you have a customer hopefully
if you have a customer and you're
working to deal with that customer and
you got a hamburger in front of you
hopefully you're going to push the
hamburger aside and work that deal
because the priority is to make money on
in the same in the same conversation
that sales manager does not believe that
sales training converts to ROI or money
so he doesn't make the time for it when
you say you don't have time if the truth
is you're saying I'm not making it a
priority because I don't think it makes
me money I had so many ups and downs so
many struggles so much rejection but to
me I never saw myself going home and to
be honest the first time I ever asked my
parents for any sort of financial help
which was so hard for me to ask him for
them because this is my dream it's not
their dream of course they want their
you know they want to see their son
succeed in their dreams but first time I
asked them for any sort of help was
right before booking Breaking Bad I was
like could you help me with my rent and
they paid my rent three months in a row
which was so hard for me to allow them
to do so and then it was so hard for
them to do it you know they had nothing
and then I book Breaking Bad and you
know the rest is history when I look
around I always learned something that
is to be always yourself and to express
yourself to have faith in yourself do
not go out and look for a successful
personality and duplicating now that
seems to me that that is the prevalent
thing happening in Hong Kong like they
always copy mannerism but they never
start from the very root of his being
and that is how can I be me
I wanted to excel my game and isolate my
game from everybody else that I was more
than just you know a few dimensional
even when it came to Magic Johnson I
mean in Magic Johnson was a crowd
pleaser he was a you know good offensive
player he was a great motivator you know
average defensive player you know I
wanted to change that I wouldn't take it
another step I want to do all those
things you know that it could separate
me from Magic Johnson you know I'm not
saying he wasn't great he still is great
but we're great in our own different way
you know and that was motivational for
me you know and to this day still is we
were running behind schedule and I had
to shoot a montage oh my god
this this montage would have taken like
five days so what I did is I I came in
there and brought everyone into one big
room all the dancers and had three
cameras I took one camera and just
stayed with John Travolta and I worked
with him and the rest I said to everyone
just dance and do whatever you want
cartwheels I say catch it all whatever
and then I sent a camera down when
they're making the stage we just put
regular light I said just shoot what you
can just no sound nothing and we put it
all together and save four days of
filming but none of that absolutely zero
was choreographed Wow in the funniest
okay John just do this yeah cut do this
cut and then I swear to God and then the
other dancers were just over there in
the corner maybe scratchy and doing a
somersault stretching and you put it all
together an amazing it's a magic over
myth yeah it's like so there are no
rules yeah so look you want to get your
work ethic so high that people actually
admire you I'm gonna ask you a question
right now do people know you because of
your unbelievable work ethic if you
can't answer yes to that man you're not
going to get in that top 10% you got to
get at the top you people have to know
you not because oh he's a good salesman
oh he's a good dish oh he's an artist so
he's a good pianist oh he's a he writes
a great you know story know did people
need to know you for one major thing
first he works he produces the guys
there every day the guys pushing and
shoving because the truth is no matter
how good your ideas are how good your
art is or how good your skillset is if
you're not working man if you're not
vibrating in a frequency that people say
my god how does that guy do all that if
you're not vibrating at that rate 10x
levels massive action tremendous work
ethic that's just a muscle nowness it's
just a discipline in your life as a way
it's a normal way that other people
think is abnormal Ryan Seacrest Tom
Cruise Oprah Steven Spielberg Donald
Trump still pumping and working as a
billionaire look if you're not working
at that level you're not gonna make it
get your work ethic in man it's the
American Way work ethic check it out
when I first moved here there I listened
to all you had to know is the strong
survive and if you're strong enough
mm-hmm you'll survive and so I've always
remembered that a good martial artist
does not become tense but ready thinking
yet not dreaming ready whatever may come
when the opponent expand like contract
when he contracts I expand and when
there is an opportunity I do not hit it
it's all by itself I miss more than
9,000 shots in my career I've lost
almost 300 games 26 times I've been
trusted to take the game-winning shot
and missed have failed over and over and
over again in my life and that is why
PASOK see I first met Bob Charlotte in
Irwin Winkler and I believe I was there
on on a casting call so we're talking a
little bit and I guess I really wasn't
right for the acting partner on the way
out I said oh I don't know if it matters
but I'd do a little bit of writing
because really he says it's yeah I'm
ready this story this I have this thing
about wrestlers and I might do some of
the boxing Wally as well bringing around
and I thought if I hadn't stopped on the
way out you know that's why I tell all
actors hover haters don't give up keep
talking eventually you might hit a nerve
somewhere to go come on back and if they
didn't say come on back or bring it
later and let's see what you've
developed I wouldn't be sitting here
the biggest struggle man was just
getting around other people that would
say I can do it I mean that's the
biggest struggle just you get around one
guy says yeah you can do it and then you
talk to him tomorrow and he's like now
it is freaking you can't do this [ __ ]
you know there's so few people telling
you to do it you know what there is a
lot of save your money
protect yourself conserve don't spend
don't take risk taking risk is the new
way to be risk adverse so we're the
biggest struggle for me was my family
man the people closest to me was the
biggest struggle every time I went out
to do another deal everybody told me you
don't need to do that man the only
person that was encouraging me was my
twin brother cuz I would see how he was
doing it dude he was making his swings
and so every time I'd get around other
people so I'll tell you a little trick I
did on weekends I would always go see
Holmes I couldn't afford that has always
inspired me I would go look I would go
drive neighborhoods literally I've done
this my entire life until I finally got
to the point where they wouldn't even
let me in the neighborhood there's
neighborhoods in Miami dude you can't
even go see you can they won't even let
you in the gates most of you can get in
if you know some of my tricks so the
point that show Vitas writing on the
board right now is you got fuel in your
tank
it wants to be accelerated on and then
you got somebody in the backseat saying
hey be careful
nobody likes a backseat driver okay so
they're sitting there they're putting
they're putting mental pressure on the
brakes when you're trying to accelerate
there's been times where I was like wow
this is really hard you know this is
really hard and then just the ups and
downs and where I'm like wow you know
I'll get like back-to-back jobs I'm like
my career is like really taking off and
then they'll just be a standstill and
it's just like you know just roll with
the punches and just deal with the
rejection and it took it took a minute
to understand that that's such a huge
part of this business and now I just
don't take it personally I just like you
know what there's someone better for the
role and you know there's another job
out there all the time people come up
and say hey troops are you really that
good I said well if I tell you I'm good
probably you will say I'm boasting I
tell you I'm no good in no one line I
never feel that I'm at my best I feel I
still have room to improve still set
goals for myself to strive for
I'm never complacent with what I've
achieved even though it's been very
successful for me I still feel I have a
lot to prove not just as a player but as
a person as a father to some extent as a
role model in all aspects
so I'm never really too complacent with
myself or with what I've achieved when I
get to a point where I feel I can't
improve as a player I'll walk away from
the game
I'm still feel that I have a plateau
that you know I hadn't reached yet in
terms of my skills all my my
expectations of myself you know I'm
always gonna expect myself to do certain
things or surpass certain things as long
as I believe that then you know my road
to success is can continue to expand and
what I'll try to do is I'll just write
longhand it on so on a legal pad I'll go
goes to here sees his mother goes to the
store because so I'll have like ten
things of beats where he's going now
gets on a horse go swimming bum buh buh
and I do that and I know in my heart 80%
of it will be no good but you're getting
through the screenplay you're getting it
done because the rewrite is always more
fun and much more enjoyable it's I don't
believe people should look for a
profession or even 50% profession in the
first draft it's always going to be kind
of this like a child scribbling but you
did it and the main thing for me is to
once you have that accomplishment to say
in - you could do it in two weeks three
weeks again maybe 10% will be good but
you've now have this sense of a Kapo
sure you did it and the rewriting
process starts and that's when the fun
begins the negativity is just negative
and there's no money in it there's no
future and being negative where's the
solution you know I can't do that we
can't do that that can't happen this is
wrong that's wrong oh my gosh taxes are
too high taxes - dude it's negative it
is negative it is negative look there's
so much abundance of negativity that by
itself tells you why there's no value in
it
there's doing like church plays since I
was like literally baby I was a bit I
was the baby Jesus I don't I don't know
if I knew then but
I think around like like eight or nine
when I was doing like kind of like the
leading roles I was obsessed with it
kind of just ran with it I said empty
your mind be formless shapeless like
water now you put water into a cup it
becomes the cup you put water into a
bottle it becomes the bottle you're
putting in a teapot it becomes the
teapot now water can flow or it can
crash be water my friend sports is it's
a tool that teaches you know and teaches
you bad things it can also teach you
good things it's how you proceed those
things I've looked at every experience
that I've had negative and positive and
taking that as a positive you know if I
wouldn't change anything because I think
it would alter some of the other things
that happen you know so when I look back
I can't say that I've had any bad things
happen sure I mean you don't want bad
things happen but you deal with bad
things you can't have good or and
without bad originally when I brought
the script to them they were fairly
enthusiastic about it the one thing they
were not enthusiastic about was me
playing the part and I really can't
blame them at the time Ryan O'Neal I was
a candidate Burt Reynolds Robert Redford
Jimmy Caan and they all you know we're
at the top of their game and so I could
see it but there was something inside of
me that that you know this opportunity
is never gonna come around and I really
wasn't used to money and I had no idea
of what I would be missing but the
temptation started to come forward first
it was 25 grands and $100,000 of my I
never heard of a hundred thousand cuz I
had had like a hundred six dollars in
the bank and like I said I had to sell
my dog and things were not looking very
very good my $40 car had just blown up
so I was taking a bus to work and was
still it didn't matter I wanted to stick
with it then went up to 150 thousand
hundred seventy-five thousand went up to
250 thousand now my head was starting to
spin and it went up to three hundred
thirty thousand and probably I heard it
well to three hundred sixty thousand and
I thought alright you know you've really
managed
poverty very well you've got this down
to a science you really don't need much
to live on I had like sort of figured it
out so I was not in in any way used to
to the good life song you know what if I
know in the back of my mind if I sell
the script and it does very very well
I'm gonna jump off a building and if I'm
not in it there's no doubt about I'm
gonna leap in front of a train I'm very
very upset so this is one of those
things where you just roll the dice and
you fly by the proverbial seat of your
pants a guy I got a try it I gotta just
to it I may be totally wrong and I'm
gonna be taking a lot of people down
with me but I just believe in it you got
to make a commitment to service you got
to make a commitment to like hey I have
a target I know that when we don't
achieve targets here in my office the
first thing I asked regardless the
internet department if it's my
accounting department on collections or
it's my sales department I'm gonna ask a
question what is the target
no target results in those sales so if
you're in parts if you're in service
look have a target measure that target
hourly if you really want to get results
measure your target every hour to see
what do we get in the last 60 minutes I
promise you do those two simple things
don't even learn anything about how to
sell anybody anything have a target
measure it every hour and I guarantee
your sales will come up I want to get
the script I just kind of dissect I read
it just front to back and then I start
really dissecting each scene and kind of
understanding why is in this particular
situation why he's feeling these four
things it's all so much on the page and
so I just how I dive into a particular
scene I just try and live those moments
as if I were Jesse I don't try and have
certain triggers or think about some
sort of torture that I personally have
went through and on my past I just try
and really live and breathe through this
particular person's skin and with Jesse
he's it's a constant it's a constant
struggle and so it's a it's a little
rough at times but it's
such a blast in case you have missed the
reasoned news she could no of which I am
the founding has been elected and
accepted into the Black Belt Hall of
Fame in America this must the first time
a recently developed form of martial art
is nationally accepted no chicken dough
is not thousands or even hundreds of
years old it started in a loud 1965 by a
dedicated and intensified man called
Bruce Lee and my martial art is
something that no serious martial artist
can ignore it's not about to shoes
it's about knowing where you're going
not forgetting where you started it's
about having the courage to fail
not breaking when you're broken taking
everything you've been given and making
something better
it's about work
before dory
and what's inside of you
what they say you can
is not about the shoes it's about what
you do in there
it's about being we were born to be
writing I almost approached it like
exercise I get up maybe at 4:30 in the
morning takes an hour to get going and
then I'll start to write about maybe
three hours and then it becomes
repetitive and the next day I get up and
even if I don't feel inspired I'll sit
there first three hours until I get the
brain says okay you must start to
produce something so I try to write
quickly and I and I follow a pattern
just the way you would be if you were in
the Army or whatever and then that gets
me through it quickly some writers will
take a year to you everyone has a
different process but that's what I do I
write better in the morning
like my mother I tried I used I used to
write at night all the time when I was
but I found that everything everyone
died it was dark and creepy you there
was a really horrible it's like very
depressing then I realized Edgar Allen
Poe used to write at night now I figure
out what within any company I have my
own I have four and five flows in every
company I don't have one flow I'm not
gonna depend on one product once I get
those four streams coming in from one
company okay for instance at this
company it's a it's an online project
called Cardone University then their
speaking gigs then there's books then
there's audios there's mp3 so those are
flows coming in for one company at some
point I'm like okay let's do a second
deal so I'm gonna then have a company
that runs parallel like a skier right I
don't want the skis crossing over I want
them to be parallel so that anything
that maybe I can't do any longer in this
company maybe I'm gonna outsource to a
partner and build a second company then
once these two are skiing along and
happy maybe I'm gonna go do a third
company out here that I have a passion
for that has nothing to do with these
first two that is not diversification
that's multiple strong flows and when I
make a bet on this third company dude I
want to take it I want to take all the
money from these first two flows and I
want to say hey if it's a good deal go
all-in
if you're not sure don't put any money
in it all folks
I always tend to gravitate towards the
more complex side of things
they're just complicated characters just
because for me that's just it's just
more interesting to play I have no fear
of opponent in front of me but I am very
self-sufficient they do not bother me
and that should I fight should I do
anything I have made up my mind and
that's it baby
you better kill me before we are old and
sure retire it's been a long season but
mentally we have a we have a vision we
have a finish that we have to attain you
know and sometimes you have to do it
when you old and you're tired you know
and I think it's the test of your will
to succeed and you have to deal with
some of these negatives and I'm pretty
sure you know by the end of this
playoffs you'll see the old and the
tired people were very very young and
strong mentally if you've never had
anything like today I will go okay I'm
selling the house you don't have
anything and you're just sitting there
you go okay I wrote this for myself and
I don't even know if it's that good but
if it's obviously someone likes it I'll
regret it I know I'll regret it night
and you know I bet I say it once a week
if I walk around thank God really all
the time all the time it's like you did
one thing right in life or you could do
a thousand things wrong just do one
thing right you it makes up for the
other 999 mistakes sometimes there's so
many mistakes salespeople make I think
you need to get down to like the main
ones but you're not selling the solution
I mean that even before that though I
would say Corinne is the biggest mistake
people are not excited they're not alive
they're not they're not showing interest
in the cycle and they lose interest I
was in Barcelona recently and I was
looking at a watch
and the cycle didn't didn't close I
could have bought the watch I was
qualified to buy the watch I'm the one
that walked myself in the shop on my
vacation to look at the watch I know
exactly the watch I was looking for and
when I left my wife said what could he
have done to close the sale I said well
he could have kept a life in the cycle
he could have kept the cycle open so
what I mean by that is look if you're
not interested if you don't believe the
cycle can be closed it will not close so
the number one mistake I think
salespeople managers and the store makes
is they assume a clothes can't be had
that day I go into every cycle every
sales cycle with every prospect every
phone call every no matter how complex
the sale is or how simple it is with the
belief that I can sell that product that
day this time now a lot of roles are
coming my way where I'm playing like the
lovable like drug addict but what I want
to do is do something completely
opposite just do something that is
different than something I've ever done
something that's kind of terrifying and
scary to me but that's what it's about
gravitate towards just such just
different kind of roles you know like I
try to do stuff it's always
terrifying you know not terrifying as a
story but it just terrifies me as an
actor to play what was that an
exhibition we emotional content
try again if you do you can think feel
it is like a finger pointing away to the
moon don't concentrate on the finger or
you will miss all that heavenly glory
maybe it's my own fault maybe I led you
to believe it was easy when it wasn't
maybe I made you think my highlight
started at the free-throw line and not
in the gym
maybe I made you think that every shot I
took was a game-winner
if my game was built on flash and not
fired maybe it's my fault that you
didn't see that failure gave me strength
that my pain was my motivation
if I led you to believe that basketball
was a guy given gift and not something I
worked for every single day of my life
maybe I'd destroy the game
oh maybe you just makin excuses give up
something to get something and I thought
I didn't have any money so I had no
phone
I painted my windows black so I didn't
know if something was up the Sun was
down all I knew was I had to write and I
wrote and I wrote it it was very bad it
wasn't good at all but every day it was
getting better and better like like a
machine like a muscle until finally the
idea for rocky came so the idea is you
must fail a hundred times to succeed
once it's that's part of it you know one
succeeds the first time it's learning
how to not get disappointed with failure
to understand failure
you only learn when you fail you don't
learn we you succeed here too but you
fail that's what you learned so that's
how I learned by lucky I was a failure
in New York and that is the reason I
started writing which made me successful
I had to teach myself early on expect to
fail expected covenant welcome it is
going to happen but don't
is that a permanent statement hey work
to your potential not your quota if you
want to stay really motivated if you
want to answer the question to why
people that have already made it keep
pushing it is because they don't operate
on quotas they operate off potential
they're driven to reach their potential
this is also tied to their ethical
obligation they know what they're
capable of nobody can tell you what
you're capable of you're the only one
that knows okay so work to your
potential not your quota quotas are
numbers who made them up some guy says
ok your quota is blah blah okay
based on what how do you come up with
that quota he only picked that quota
that number because he thinks is
significant are compared to other people
maybe in your in
history look don't operate on quotas you
want them clearly you want them but you
want to be driven to reach your
potential not just some number some
mechanics hey my potential I know nobody
else knows that I know what it is you
know yours work to your potential not
just a quota and I promise you you will
be on fire
day and night embrace every moment you
know because it flies by just embrace
everything and I've really taken that to
heart and I've haven't you know embraced
everything well you know everyone talks
to me about Bruce Lee because Bruce Lee
and I were very good friends and we
trained together for like three years
before he left for Hong Kong to pursue
his movie career and I didn't hear
anything from Bruce for like two years
then out of the blue Bruce calls me he
says I've done two movies in Hong Kong
and they're really successful I want to
do a movie now with a fight scene that
everyone will remember and I want to do
the fight scene in the Coliseum in Rome
and I want you to be my opponent at that
time I held the world title and
kiddingly I say to Bruce I said well who
wins Bruce and he says I win I'm the
star of this movie and I said oh I see
you want to beat the world champion he
said no I don't I want to kill the world
champion
right here
the bells come with it unbelievable 13
seconds left Jordan left side my
practice is if I'm playing the game so
when the moment comes in the game it's
not new to me that's the beauty of the
game of basketball that's the reason why
you practice that's the effort so when
you get to that moment you don't have to
think instinctively things happen
Bulls lead 8786 Michael Jordan with 45
points yes
yeah I think it was a very defining
moment of what my career was in Chicago
there's six NBA championship
of Michael Jordan how magnificent is it
but somewhere along the line you changed
you stopped being you you let people
stick a finger in your face and tell you
you're no good and when things got hard
you started looking for something to
blame like a big shadow let me tell you
something you already know the world
ain't all sunshine and rainbows it's a
very mean and nasty place and I don't
care how tough you are it will beat you
to your knees and keep you there
permanently if you let it you me or
nobody is gonna hit as hard as life but
it ain't about how hard you hit it's
about how hard you can get hit and keep
moving forward how much you can take and
keep moving forward that's how weird it
is done now if you know what you're
worth the glottic get what you're worth
but you gotta be willing to take the
hits and not pointing fingers saying you
ain't where you wanna be because of him
or her or anybody cowards do that in
that ain't you you're better than that
hey Grant Cardone I just want to give
you a little encouragement here on
Thursday afternoon this week I have been
in Detroit Buffalo New York City I was
on my way to Hartford it got cancelled
because of some situations whoa I just
dropped my back why am I telling you all
this okay now I came to the wrong
terminal I'm gonna walk back to - I'm
not asking you to feel sorry for me I'm
doing this as an encouragement video
dude things don't go right you got to
push harder you got to spend money that
you didn't think you were gonna spend
hang in there don't quit do not quit
push
okay I know how hard it is I know it's
hard I know there's moments where
everybody thinks oh my god what am i
doing just keep pushing your family
needs you to do it we need you to do it
god bless america definitely need you to
do it and so hang in there keep pushing
when you think about quitting just
understand that everybody you compete
with is having the very same thought
last-man-standing baby
most of us have recovered enough to go
on rod who's our next player well let's
see what can do for Erina Sturdevant
I have the horrible feeling I have
another one there's the next item up for
bid an elegant laptop desk Aaron what do
you bid on that 1,200 bucks
1,200 bucks
775 775 charlena
800 800 dollars crazy 850 bourbon is 850
actual retail price 1797
congratulations Aaron believe it or not
I have another one of these honey
we play the dice game light up the first
number in the price of the car please
here are the dice now remember there are
no zeros in the price of the car there
are no numbers higher than six roll and
let's hope it's the second number in the
price the first number is 1 now you'll
grow the 1 is that the second number no
there's the second number higher or
lower than higher of course it has to do
okay
next number in the price of the car is
it six Darren we're on a hot streak is
it three no is it higher or lower than
three higher than three alright roll
that last number is it four
no is it higher or lower than four lower
than four let's find out does Aaron win
the car light up the second number
please light up the third number please
give us a number higher than three yes
give us a number lower than four
sorry bro be back after this thank you
guys so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed I'd love to know what you think
if you want to leave a comment below I
appreciate it and team to believe
continue to achieve great things and
I'll see you soon